I know what they say about
me about hopeless
Romantics that we're
weak and I'm not
weak I learned the hard
way not all love stories have a happy
ending turns up let's pick this back up
next week I just want to what are you
guys doing here we think you might be a
sex addict every time I see you what
maybe I'm still
in thir times a charm this guy don't
stand a chance this is me haven't been
sleeping well
lately I guess I never have this is me I
was I used to share a room with my
sister she used to sleep so peacefully
this is me and I just used to lie there
awake
[Music]
thinking how does anybody sleep that way
when your heart never goes to
sleep I know you feel like nobody gets
you I don't even get me this is me it's
never enough for you he's a liar I've
never lied to you and the constant
criticism she thinks I'm her employee
me being with you feels like home with
me but I left home for a
[Music]
reason whenever someone asked me what I
wanted to be when I grew
up my answer was
always in
love you must respect the E and flow of
the universe this is
me this is me
[Music]
now